I wouldn't say it was a dilemma,
but it was a.
It was a problem and it was a a not
uncommon problem for a big global
company in the early 19 nineties,
we started to do global sourcing and
what that means is you're basically
buying a either product or sub
assemblies or things that go into
products from companies outside the
United States where you have a
contractual relationship with them.
They're not your employees,
they're third parties.
The question was would we impose ethical
sourcing on those companies and by that
we mean that you make sure that they had
no prisoner child labor,
that they had decent environmental
standards,
that they had decent wages and decent
working conditions and decent living
conditions.
If the employees in fact lived on the
facilities.
We had no legal obligation to do that
because these were not our facilities.
These were not our employees,
but we decided that we would require
this of our sourcing partners because it
was important to do for at least three
reasons.
Number one,
we were concerned that there might be
enforcement of law against them which
would stop supply even though
enforcement in some of these countries
like China is very erratic.
Number two,
we were very concerned about our
employees morale if we had one set of
standards 50 miles away,
but allowed much poor standards in our
suppliers.
That would be,
I think for at least some employees.
Very disconcerting.
Why were we being so hypocritical?
One standard in our plants and other
standard somewhere else,
especially when those standards could be
very injurious to the public.
For example,
one of the early suppliers I went to in
China was literally putting mercury from
making light bulbs in the sluice ways
which went into the rice paddies,
which we of course put a stop to a and
then the third reason,
at least in the company that I worked
for is that we were an icon of
globalization and one of the criticisms
of globalization is that you're
exporting bad practices that you
wouldn't do at home.
So we felt that it was important that in
our supply chain we not allow these
kinds of bad practices.
That would be an example of a decision
that we made was not required by law
that you could call.
It was an ethical decision,
something beyond what the law requires,
which we gave a lot of thought to and
very early in the,
in the early nineties,
mid nineties,
started to have a program when we
qualified suppliers that they had to
meet these other conditions involving
child labor,
prison labor environment.
So on.
Not just that they made good products in
their finances were okay.
So that would be an example of how you
reason about establishing a global
ethical standard beyond what the law
requires.